hello alex how are you i'm good conan
this is awesome hey sona hi okay i'm
i i just have to comment on this uh
uh because i'm looking at alex you're of
course all listening but uh alex is uh
oh so i think it's fair to say this is a
very handsome man yeah yeah yeah this is
you were taken aback by it i kind of
noticed that you saw him and you were
like oh it's not it's not my fault
we're on uh we're on we're on zoom and i
i just
i got rattled for a second and just
instinctively tried to kiss him uh and
then realized what's a zoom i you know
and a little hard yeah with the computer
screen and the internet and the cables
and stuff yeah and then there's the
whole wife and she's like well what's
that all about that would be well come
on you always you always you always
suspected you know and then it's also
just very inappropriate to just meet
someone right away and then just try to
kill you you hear that kind of weird i
consider it brave
it's popular in europe okay let's let's
uh let's get to the the crux of the
matter alex you're a fine looking fellow
and uh you look like you're wearing like
safari gear i constantly i looked at the
available wardrobe options and wife and
said full steve irwin let's go
so that's cool yeah thank you steve
irwin you have a steve irwin vibe and
also i'm looking at your
room behind you
and is that
i mean it looks like you've got really
cool stuff it looks like you're living
in a very cool space this is our house
uh it's built in 1918 so zero insulation
but we filled it with this weird my wife
is a very patient woman i've just filled
it with my brain everywhere so
she puts up with a lot got it
very nice now tell us what you do first
of all what part of the world are you in
what do you do tell us about yourself
i'm in sonoma california and i'm a okay
anthropologist and professional safari
guide oh you are a safari guy
hence this oh so the safari gear is
yeah you've earned it it's not an
affectation you are a you're a safari
guide so that you should be having and
owning clothes like that um where do you
lead safaris mostly south africa oh have
you been i've never i've never been on a
uh to south africa i've never been on a
safari
um i've never seen any uh you know
african animals
i'm intrigued by the whole thing tell us
what that's like so how long have you
been doing this for so i i kind of back
pedal i guess i i've been doing this for
about five years but i've been i've been
working in the public speaking arena as
a park ranger for about
uh 10 years off and on i started with
the california state parks eventually
just decided because it's been like a
lifelong obsession africa is where i
want to go you know as a kid it was
always
african stories african movies african
adventure tales that kind of stuff also
i mean they just win in every animal
category so you can't you know look
yeah like what are you gonna oh look
there's another brown bear
you know there's uh if we oh look
there's the same kind of snake we saw
two days ago and the day before that you
know it gets old but in africa you've
hit the jackpot right well it's i think
it's perspective because if people from
there came here they'd be like oh my god
a bear but no they wouldn't no they
wouldn't sure no they wouldn't yeah no
they wouldn't that's fair i know they
wouldn't anyone here
yeah anyone who grew up seeing elephants
bears rhinos
giraffes i'm sorry you say it's
perspective but it's not they would come
here and go oh look a squirrel
how terrifying and then they would laugh
at our faces they have squirrels in
africa yeah yeah but they're i think
they're 60 feet tall they are they're
actually known for that and big sharp
teeth yes uh they're
more of a velociraptor than a squirrel
there um but anyway so okay
so you lead these tours
and
you are
what's that like i mean you're taking
people i've never been on one i've
always wanted to go
but are you the guy that's driving the
land rover with no
you know hood on it i mean no ceiling on
it uh roof are you the one that's
driving the land rover right up to the
rhino yeah by getting a little too close
totally i i started doing that and then
have now evolved to very smartly in
march of 2020 started my own safari
company
great time to start a travel company um
so i kind of shifted roles from being
primarily the guy driving the truck to
now it's more of a hosting role my job
is to entertain the guests make them
feel comfortable happy you know just
bring them through their whole
experience but ultimately yeah the guy
physically driving the car and showing
people wildlife and i have to say i've
learned so much about doing my job from
listening to you guys on this podcast
because when you guys start talking
about
comedy and stand-up i'm like all of that
is exactly what i'm doing because it's
all
based in live performance you're in
front of people and it's making people
happy it's making people engaged and you
know try to laugh at something or feel
like they're being entertained so i've
learned a hell of a lot about my job
from you guys
okay i have to say alex no one has ever
said that they've learned anything from
this podcast
i'm the first and
i think this is a this is a real
mark of your low character it is how am
i going to oh
oh
no i'm sorry i i just so i mean do you
get scared when you're driving up to
these incredibly unpredictable
animals that can kill you in half a
second do you have fear or no
no i'm gonna go with the macho answer no
i have no fear um sure i mean
it's it's once you get comfortable
around big animals that you start to
realize
you can read patterns you can read their
behaviors you know they're just like us
so it's it's more about personal space
at that point like you don't want to get
right up next to something if you don't
have to you got to read what it's doing
um
it's hard to translate to people that
have maybe never seen it because
you know you're talking about a ten
thousand pound elephant and people
automatically are like oh my god that's
the scariest thing i've ever seen in my
life but it's also the most majestic
thing you've ever seen and now i'm going
to take you in a car and get as
physically as close to it as i possibly
can just to freak you out because if
i've got my a-game on i'm reading the
animal i'm understanding what's
happening while still giving it enough
space to feel comfortable have you ever
completely misread an animal not yet
okay all right like you're like trust me
i'm ch this this water buffalo is not
vibing me at all he seems really whoa
i'm sorry
you're dead i've had weird encounters
like when i was at guiding academy so
that was two months of living in the
bush in a small pup tent uh and total
immersive experience they want you
exposed every single day to just
anything that could go wrong so snake in
the tent been there done that no water
in camp been there done that i got up
one night to go to the bathroom which we
had like latrines built outside
and it was one of those moonlit nights
you're under that just epic african
starry sky
and you know spider senses tingle and
you're like
what what is that shadow and i look and
there's just a lion standing there about
eight feet away from me and we're both
equally freaked out by each other so
it's this weird moment of like i'm gonna
go my way if you go your way and i just
zip the tent up and
peed my pants oh my god mission
accomplished then yeah headed out the
other way to urinate um yeah oh i'm
sorry
my main question was going to be did you
eventually get to empty the urine and he
answered my question
so empty the year what other i mean um
so you've not been attacked you've not
been charged you've pretty much uh uh
had a a charmed life as a safari guy
well no that's not to say that there's
there's been situations that could get
ugly fast and everybody says animal you
know animals oh that's a dangerous
animal and i'm like
is it though i mean any person could be
dangerous i i instead i'd rather call
animals hazardous and again it's about
reading them so i've been in situations
where
we haven't and i wasn't the one driving
but we haven't correctly read what was
happening and been charged by things and
usually that's kind of a hey you're up
in my business moment that kind of thing
um i've been stalked by leopards on foot
i've had crazy situations with rhinos
and it's more of like a
i don't know it's like a gamble like you
chose to be in that environment so
i love how you're being kind of vague
you said crazy situations with rhinos
and
you're not specific so to me that means
maybe you
uh got in on a timeshare with a rhino
and and it didn't financially turned out
to be like a bad move and the rhino's
like no i'm using it memorial day week
and you're like no we talked about this
you used it no this is completely you
can't have memorial day and labor day
and then i was like hey what the [ __ ]
you know you didn't say anything so
i'm assuming it wasn't a time share
problem with the rhino that's usually
the way it goes down no um my favorite
and i don't know favorites a weird term
there was in guiding academy of all
things we were out learning about
guiding people on foot which is a whole
other experience because
you're vulnerable you're you know
totally exposed and our instructor
stopped to look at a tree and he's going
on and on it's an ancient redwood tree
leadwoods live for hundreds and hundreds
of years so he's talking about it and
we're all fascinated and then wasps
started coming out of it and
stung my leg which felt kind of like
having a cigarette lighter just shoved
into your skin right right
so my legs start swelling i can't walk
and
there's a saying in south africa which
is tia this is africa just go with it so
our instructor our instructor looked at
my leg and went tia we're gonna go find
a black rhino so i'm hobbling on the
trail to find this black rhino which we
did find
and i would i would have to say that's
probably been the most frightening
experience in my life because black
rhino so you got
okay so uh oh i'm sorry keep going keep
going i didn't mean to interrupt you all
right well black rhinos are known for
being a little bit more
territorial whereas a white rhino is
going to be
kind of chill most of the time the the
joke is the chubby unicorn um so to find
a black light on foot totally exposed
with a swollen leg with a wasp sting in
it i was like if this dude freaks out
i'm not gonna make it back to camp oh my
god you are so cool well now listen
that is so don't you want to you conan
do you want to kind of want to be alex
i was going a different way sona i mean
i think
alex is cool but i think i and i
encounter dangers like that all the time
in my life i no no alex nothing like on
my show over the years uh oh my god no a
celebrity comes out i don't i have to
read that celebrity i have to figure out
you know uh you know is well
will ferrell is carmen elektra you know
are these people uh in the right mood uh
and they attack occasionally um
you and i have both dealt with the exact
same level of danger